all right so you have your your PO set
right and now you're doing a uh on iido
technique and really what it adds is
keep the the same internal organization
the same internal mechanics so to speak
but add the my so the timing and the
space is now part of the technique okay
so don't do anything different don't
don't go back to weirdness okay like
you're your shoulders and that kind of
stuff so you still have your pns you do
your
patterns I have the inward spiral which
is wrist in elbow out but not further
than your Y Line and then the other one
is elbow in elbow
in wrist out so the outward
spir
then don't just push
him heel
through into the
center turn the
quad you back you back to uh your ieto
handh holding because you're supposed to
create this spinal displacement okay
that's what I working
with
moving so for example my your H my hand
should never get here cuz you changed
your articulation in your elbow and I
should have never got there on you
either because that means I'm in your
arm okay so from from touch I'm in that
Center and then now you have the foot
maneuver so you can't lose it so the
same
structure I don't lose as I
move don't don't lose it okay and then
now so now you have your
eys stay there so your hand has to be
head
level it's going to make your arm at a
45° angle okay and just like all coku
hole the energy is over here not here
under you
you over here but I'm not here okay so
I'm here like this and I release and
drop the
cheek and that's what you're trying to
push on and I drop you're done you're
done
okay so some
mistakes you have
two Y moves in the elbows now
okay um once here in yielding is the I
key going this
way not need to be taken that far though
okay and then the C the I key boom loads
the C hand okay on the inward
side the
quock closed here on the right and
then it transfers over
boom drop the
chi all right
and you you're going to try to push back
on that okay Margaret you can even turn
your body back that
way yield more in that left
hand and then it goes off when you
move he
okay
ding see how she
falls hang here for forever okay you
have to have a yield
it's just a controlled yield okay so if
she's if she's pulling you're still
going to do
it you get it it's not
it's meaning it's not mean just
collapsing there's a Integrity to it
such that you can't pull against it
pulls you in you see but it's not
holding you up the reason it's holding
her up on you is you have positive y on
there she's bracing on it you you'll
have to allow it to go out where it
makes her fall without pulling her did
you get that okay so that's what that
hand is doing that hand is making
her I'm not using
this PES my sty
that that her falling into it is what
generates the Y
hand get that little percussion over
okay and then once you feel the
projection so I'll I'll do it audibly it
goes boom right she go that's when I you
don't that that's your want to control
your cowardice
okay all you got one job okay push don't
let go don't hit your head okay long
percuss and I move into that
okay once you feel it go
off it's not off off and then you
move once it
percusses you're in you're
pushing yep and I
am relax
dropping push push push you can you can
St that you can drive all into this
okay I'm not pinning her my hands are
just here okay she's tired okay so UK
decides how long they're going to push
for but if you feel yourself on UK's
push go
okay and I'm here you
see this is not correct
extend don't lean towards
me that would not be correct okay but
assuming you are correct UK
decides I'm just getting tired okay
stop
then all right you have to resist like I
know he's doing some sort of front
inward
kazushi but you don't paint
that
okay so by
itself this is going that way okay it's
going this way
[Music]
you you
seeking that you did
[Music]
that stay there
okay you didn't turn over do you
understand okay come here
that this one
is
doing
[Music]
this so this one's not going like
this and this one's not going like
this why why would I do this when that
hand was already doing
it so I get you
here then I push
this
okay this arms just like I just pulled
it just do
that then this
hand makes that hip
go and then
inside that
fall I
rotate my
body from far to
far so I create it and then I move my
foot but my hands don't you was my hands
my hands are not rotating like I'm
turning a
stering the hands are doing the same
thing the quad
moves you're going to fall off of that
weight as it passes me that allows
me so here you're driving wait I don't
want you to
atig may make a kind of loose contact
where you're not fatigue okay so not
doing that into
you you just stay loose I don't want you
to Tire just so you can feel that
pressure there okay and then I now
release
tension you see right that's that's the
G sinking now so once I release and now
you try to
lift and we're not going anywhere okay
I'll release seon
more you
see and that's what makes it cou
ho
okay and that's what you're doing in the
C you set that's what you're trying to
release we're just standing you see
um that's what you do at all the end of
iido ke pins they're not pins they're C
you release
the the that way it just drops and
things get heavy okay
um it's not a pin I'm not pinning you I
am using
your
resistance to
trigger tension in the untrained so that
I can practice the trained response
which is drop and SN the cheek okay
um so we've left the C the pure
cultivation fields of the C set for
example the I
set um they're simplified fields and
simplified in what way there's no mind
to them that that's what there's no M
there's no required timing or required
spatial relationship
in
fact
uh the long the
longer and the slower or the more
still the better in the cultivation set
but when you move
towards kihon what you're doing is
you're
you're you're making more
complex the field how
particular by now making my relatives my
means space time but it means corre the
correct space time for the desired
objective okay those things have to go
it means SpaceTime it means correct
correct to what correct to the desired
objective okay now that's a
lot that's three more factors that are
interrelated that you put into this so I
don't really consider this as good a
cultivation field as the
C set or the I set you're you're trying
to now take what you've learned in the
cultivation sets and add other things to
them my okay so when you add
my even though this looks pretty simple
and looks very much like
uh a cultivation field as in the koku
set or the II
set it's not it's much closer to how EO
is or Shon like other
Kona and so it should be more consistent
with those kihon waza and something that
is consistent with that kihon waza in
terms of what my is is your angle of
deviation you have to have an angle of
deviation but yet here in this kofu hole
it looks like there's no angle deviation
but it's not true there is okay
um and that that th that angle is
connected in the qua movement okay so if
you look
at the relationship between my spine and
Sean's spine our noses here when I when
I open or close one claw you see how I'm
moving off the line of the T you see so
he comes to punch me in the nose right
and I that was enough then that's enough
for me to miss so I'll redo my quaw undo
my quaw and you see that's that's dead
hit okay so and this is kind of what's
trapping you on why you hold her is you
don't you keep your paaw here until it's
time to push it so you go here and then
you'll do that claw you see but the
first CLA
is and this this starts what Margaret is
noticing in my body so this this
movement let's look at what I do so I'm
going here get out of the way of that
arm okay so I'm going
wom and then V Okay so that makes this
movement one
[Music]
big wind up as opposed
to it and I just push there it's I'm
basically winding
up that movement right
okay yes you're working on the quaw but
the quaw here because it's not a
cultivation field is simultaneously
generating your angle
deviation that your
tesak is you see how we've moved you
went left I went right
okay and that's how that's what you're
seeing margar is that big
movement okay but think of it as as and
and you mentioned that you get kind of
squeezed you see so here here I am
squeezed okay but if I just could move
this over I not squeez you see that even
though this is close to me it doesn't
really have anything on it you
see like if you before you get squeezed
if you moved off the line then there's
nothing on it you wouldn't have got
squeez you got squeeze CU you stayed on
the line okay and you didn't deviate you
didn't have the angle of deviation that
is built into the qua utilization in the
technique okay so let's try that bring
attention to that